what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we got ourselves
a trailer for the diego luna shout
out and door baby anywho guys if
you could leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated leave your thoughts down below
also what you thought about the trailer and
also subscribe and click that notification
bell because tonight at midnight two episodes
of obi-wan drops so we are going to record
our reactions for it take a few hours put together
so keep a lookout that's why you have to click
that notification bell and lastly today's video
is actually sponsored by headspace when i'm very
very excited to be partnered up with them they
changed my life that was the first app that got
me into meditation and i've been meditating
for many years since i know john does as well
and this month the headspace also has some fun
star wars themes but more details on that after
the reaction please stick around because i'm
very much excited for it anywho let's do this
ah
wow
this already looks so damn gritty
this looks intense the empire is coming
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they're everywhere i love this music
they're watching me now come on
soon enough these days will end
there will be no rules going forward
that's what a reckoning sounds like
cool
definitely looks like it's in the
rogue one side of the galaxy that looks
absolutely beautiful i see a
couple things back looks like
okay so we got mom mothma back very important
rebel figure who was also in rogue one as well
and this looks like the imperial senate right
here showcasing some of the transition it was
just like palpatine stepped in this is part of
the transition but right here oh yeah you got that
those are clone troopers baby cool we're gonna
see clone troopers live action yay instead of
just a flashback in the boat with fett show
i'm excited about that anywho guys uh yeah
we're gonna talk more about this in a second but
first a word from our sponsor headspace and uh
again very excited to be working with them we
want to thank today's video sponsor headspace
now you guys might have heard me say from time
to time that i meditate regularly and it all
first started with this app headspace and it's an
app that i know john actually uses regularly now
thanks to me right it's all your fault and so for
this month they have partnered up with disney star
wars for your find your force mindfulness series
which i think actually works in conjunction with
the way of the jedi so well literally meditation
has changed my life i can confidently say
headspace is a major contribution to that factor
so i'm excited that we're finally partnering
up with them especially considering it's mental
health awareness month plus it's perfect timing
because we got a ton of new star wars content
on the horizon and with their find your four
series they have sleep cast breathing exercises
and guided meditations from some of your favorite
star wars characters including yoda chewbacca r2d2
the list goes on you know i've opened up about my
prior diagnosis in the past the most helpful thing
has been meditation it's something i very much
heavily encouraged one step closer to feeling like
a calm confident jedi so if you want to download
headspace and find your force today head on down
to our link in the description box download the
app and get meditating do some deep breathing hang
out with yoda yeah i don't really know anything
about the show to be totally frank with you guys
i didn't even know stone skarsgard was in here
i liked diego luna a lot as an actor and door
was a highlight one of the highlight characters
of rogue one a movie that i've actually only
seen one time i really liked it but i just
haven't made the time to re-watch it since i saw
that one time in the theaters but this has a lot
that that grit and is tony gilroy involved in this
one too oh yeah i mean he's been talking a lot
about the show and kind of going on record saying
that this is gonna take a bunch of characters
that you know from the legacy from the canon and
maybe re-contextualize them or maybe show you why
what you know about them might not be the
truth you didn't go into super specifics
but it seems like he is adamant about making
this a bold show in terms of choices made
surrounding the canon but also i mean like i
really love the imagery here because it does
embody that sort of rougher grittier side of
the galaxy and diego luna has described this as
being a show about a migrant and about somebody
whose you know home and culture is essentially
crushed by the empire and who then must find a
new place to lay roots and also find a new cause
basically saying like at the beginning of this
he doesn't really care about the rebels or any of
you know like the political situation going
on and it's about him finding that motivation
to take up arms to become an intelligence
officer to do the things the acts that we see
eventually in rogue one and i feel like they at
least here in this tease have done a really nice
job of making it feel like a ground level and a
sort of intense show in terms of those personal
human stakes our you know homes are being
destroyed and beset upon by this you know
insidious ideology and watching those crucial kind
of last moments before it all boils over into the
conflict that we all know and love from star wars
itself you know yeah in some ways you know we had
star wars rebels the animated series in some ways
this is like the live-action rebels to a certain
extent not like an adaptation but considering that
this takes place before episode four and that this
is again you know going into the rise of the
rebellion we're gonna have mon mothman here very
important figure in the rebellion i'm excited to
see like all the nitty gritty details and i feel
like the show might actually explore some of those
political transitions and debates as well you know
even though we've had stuff like the mandalorian
within the book of boba fett which are you know
canon and tied in obviously this seems like
it's going to be more direct towards obviously
leading into rogue one which feeds into the bigger
development of the galactic empire oh look jump
cut there's a cat here i guess what i'm getting
at is like those shows told these different
stories well this is going to be focusing on
the wars in star wars and a big contributing
to the development of that significantly uh if
if that makes sense to what i'm getting at yeah
either the political or the physical aspects of
the war as we've seen up until this point so i
think bringing that quality to life of something
that feels more gritty and grounded and watching
the heroine take that this has on no yeah yeah
yeah no no no no no cats get views you should
have been in the reaction for the thumbnail you
should know this you know seeing like the heroin
take that it has on like the civilians and these
different individuals like what i imagine we'll
be seeing you know how diego luna indoors family
was affected the development of his relationship
with k2so when you're looking at those people and
seeing the fear in them and just really seeing
the turmoil that the galactic empire brings
so much of the time we're just caught up in
you know the the main characters or like the
badass ones who are getting involved in the
fight and it's only just like a cut too quick
to see a couple of reactions i want this show
to kind of break my heart a little bit to see the
characters in this galaxy truly affected in a way
that makes you go back to i hate the empire you
know but yeah guys and or trailer what did you
guys think leave your thoughts down below uh
please subscribe and click that bell because
we got you know everyone coming up tonight uh
or we'll be up for you guys tomorrow morning
and thank you to headspace for sponsoring
this video and we will catch you guys soon